foreign
[Music]
oh there you are look at you look at you
I can't see you
big news yesterday yes I finally
finished my jigsaw puzzle it took months
look at that huh
but also Johnny Depp won his defamation
case against his ex Amber Heard
foreign
Court though he was in London jamming
with guitar legend Jeff Beck I believe
we have tape
[Music]
hold on I got it hold on
don't do drugs kids
because they're mine
but apparently when the jurors heard
what A Turd heard was it spurred the
herd to give her the bird
sorry I like poetry because that makes
me a nerd
but she crapped the bed in court and in
bed
and the jury saw what we saw that she
had a lousy case because she was a lousy
liar which is weird for an actress since
she lies for a living her job is to
pretend to be someone else maybe her
lawyers should have gotten Scarlett
Johansson to play her in court laughs
so Amber defamed a dude in one of the
worst ways he can she abused the metoo
movement and probably destroyed what was
left of it in the process she just
figured all you got to do is point a
finger and click believe all women a
sexist would say but it became obvious
that she was so full of crap that she
was leaving it in their bed
you could see it we could see it the
jury could smell it or maybe Depp just
needed a bath
but you know who couldn't see it the
Washington Post they published her
article that at ACLU lawyer claims was
Ghost written eluding that Depp was a
violent abuser but what if the post
could see the claim was shaky but it
didn't matter to them I mean what's
depth gonna do Sue you got to Wonder Too
how involved the post was in this did
they help her and the ACLU Goose upper
Pros did they coordinate with their
publicity Department said she had a
movie coming up
but who cares the post thought what's
the worst that could happen and usually
they're right that's the real lesson
here would you be able to do what Johnny
Depp did if an ex or anyone decided to
destroy you in the world of public
opinion luckily that may never happen
but what if it did you know it happened
to me I still can't believe it after all
all I did for hammer
but most of us don't have the
wherewithal to fight back the way Depp
did it's like falling into a porta potty
you get smeared you stay smeared and no
one wants to get near you that's why I'm
no longer welcome at construction sites
but Deb he paid for the best lawyers in
the world and he won so hooray for
Johnny Depp except
do I really care about him that much I
mean he's no saint he even said that
about himself he probably hates Fox he
even joked about killing Trump and
really you can't make six Pirates of the
Caribbean movies and not enjoy torturing
people
so forget about him for now the real
question is what about the Washington
Post they were the ones who published
this article why are they named and
shouldn't they be sued to someone should
get Nick sandman's lawyer on the phone
because that's really the only way to
stop this crap
well that and cutting people's tongues
out but Fox legal has informed me that I
should call that procedure problematic
so Steph scored one against cancer
culture and for that he deserves credit
but what about the Press
I bet misheard likely never had to back
her story up with me too on her side and
an editor especially if it's a male one
knew better than to ask if she had any
proof believe all women a sexist would
say and they figured they could get by
simply by not naming him obviously
knowing everyone would figure it out
it's Johnny Depp not Governor Huckabee
this time
joking
I'm joking that was a joke but it's like
if I said my co-worker my co-worker at
Fox who's really cool and fun but maybe
she parties a little too hard you know
everyone knows
it's Kaylee mcenany no oh
yeah
and you wonder why people think media
are scum actually you don't wonder
anybody who has looked up at a TV in the
airport gets it now Johnny does too
maybe he can play Nick Sandman in the
movie there you go
so Depp's Victory feels good but will it
feel good to those who will never taste
such a win because they don't have the
Deep Pockets or the depth pockets
see what I did there
that's why I sit here
I mean how many other stories has the
Washington Post published where the
claims were just as false don't answer
that the show only lasts an hour and I
don't want to cut into evil Shannon
bream's time
you don't know what she's like when she
gets mad
it's kind of fun actually but you'll
never know for sure because those people
weren't deaf
depth so they'll keep doing it unless
more depths call them on their
but how many of us make 20 million
dollars a picture well besides me in the
streets of New York City danger lurks
around every corner for some confronting
evil is a part of life but after
squatting down one man stood up with his
number two coming this summer Greg
Gutfeld is the time traveling Buccaneer
scientist mechanic veterinarian who
throws his own feces at his enemies
yeah let's welcome tonight
you can see her every day at noon and
every night in Jim acosta's nightmares
co-host about numbered in former White
House Press Secretary Kaylee mcadary
it's like a great cocktail he could
shake things up and is excellent on Ice
vice president of public relations for Z
Labs Chris Barron
her voice has Guantanamo Bay inmates
screaming bring back waterboarding
contributor cat Tim
and he does the limbo under the Brooklyn
Bridge my massive sidekick in the NWA
World Television Champion Tyrus
Kaylee welcome to the show always a
pleasure having you here people don't
realize you're just two offices away
from me it's so fun next yeah you're
next door to me actually oh yes yeah
yeah so we see each other we're like
neighbors oh yeah but sometimes I'll
steal your newspaper sometimes I can
hear you through the wall really what am
I doing yeah oh you're saying all sorts
of untoward things I won't go to HR
don't worry oh thank God you know does
this boil down to like Depp is no saint
he's a mess
self-destructive but his it's
self-destructive it's not outwardly
destructive like that's the kind of the
I think that's the thing that people
might have noticed between her and him
is that like like all the stuff he does
is to himself where she points her stuff
at him and that because this is on TV we
get to analyze it so people you know
it's not on us it's on them for
televising it so we get to like finger
paint with their psyche all we want yeah
no very self-destructive and you know if
we want to choose someone to be the face
of due process let's go with someone
like I don't know Brett Kavanaugh maybe
yeah instead of Johnny that that being
said
um I wish I could go back to a day where
Johnny Depp was just Jack Sparrow and I
didn't know who Amber Heard was that was
a beautiful day in my life
um but you make the key point I haven't
heard anyone make it yet about having
the resources to go after someone for
lying about you and as you're doing this
monologue I'm just thinking during my
tenure I mean Trump was lied about every
day you know that he dispared Fallen
Soldiers lie that he gassed and pumbled
protesters to have a photo op at a
church lie that's been disproven uh but
what's another one there's many many he
has Deep Pockets or debt Pockets we
could say yes but who has the energy to
go after all of these lies yeah no in
fact I mean in fact I mean I remember
that he was like he would talk about it
constantly and then like everybody would
just dismiss it say oh it's Trump and we
you know they his critics don't believe
him and then they all turn out to be
true later yeah you know Chris she
looked great as usual thank you thank
you thank you Fox News makeup ladies the
the clutch here uh do we have to call
them ladies no we don't have to but
my mom would be mad if I didn't say that
what did you make of the uh uh the did
you follow this closely no I I mean I
tried not to like I mean it felt like
voyeuristic and like the worst possible
it could be except it's on TV I know but
like that it still felt voyeuristic in
the worst
open I can watch that you can but should
you should you tell other people should
you talk about it that was just one
night that I brought all right all right
all right all right I've never
complained yes I kept quiet about it I
didn't go to HR either
no but actually I think an excellent
point that you made and that you echoed
there is the idea that you know Johnny
Depp is is singularly situated to be
able to fight back and not just
singularly situated because of the the
wealth because it doesn't matter if he
ever works again you know he doesn't he
didn't have to do anything he's Johnny
Depp he can go hang out in London with
Beck and play the guitar or do whatever
average citizens who get abused by the
mainstream media have no Outlet in fact
I've got a friend of mine Jim
Worthington who owns a gym in
Pennsylvania who was called an
insurrectionist after January 6 because
he helped pay for buses to send people
from Bucks County down to DC to hear the
president speak at the ellipse he
actually fought back he actually filed a
lawsuit against moveon.org that is
pending right now and I said to him all
the time I'm like why are you doing this
why are you spending all kinds of money
and he said I'm doing it because the
people out there who can't exactly
people out there who have been smeared
by the media all the time who have no
opportunity to fight back that's a great
story that's a great story I hope he
wins that yeah I do too and and we meet
you the point you made about where's the
Washington Post in this where is the
accountability where's the
accountability for any of the outlets
that lied about President Trump I mean
they've got you know Pulitzer Prize
prizes for telling lies about President
Trump no accountability whatsoever we
just you know pretend like it never
happened see Jim Acosta sitting where
Amber Heard was sitting wouldn't that be
a beautiful day then I would watch that
I would watch that all right you kids
Iris
virus Tyrus tires we don't lie around
here no we talked but we played so the
truth even when we lie even when we lie
exactly what are you any what what is
your brain telling you well first of all
I I will always say that all women
should be heard
not believed nice
heard I like that and the investigation
should be respected right cat we respect
the investigation you need to be able to
have two thoughts probably the most
frustrating thing as a man watching this
is that when someone is wronged to the
point of how death was wronged
there's this argument that he shouldn't
fight it because it's not fair for those
who were really wronged right that when
has that type of thinking ever been
accepted you know like I know you didn't
murder your wife Tyrus but somebody
somebody else did and if you get off
yeah it will make other murder you know
and I'm like no I still didn't do it I'm
not going to jail so it's the same thing
it's like hearing that it's it's a bad
day for the metoo movement because the
truth was told
that's not right and we can't have that
thing she is a liar she doesn't
represent women she doesn't represent
Abused Women she doesn't represent
anyone but liars and criminals and we
need to be able to say that she has
individually achieved this honor and
other women are not responsible for it
so I'm tired of hearing that when
somebody makes an accusation even when
even when you fight it and you win it
you still have collateral damage that
you're never going to be the same yeah
you're never going to you say one of the
things he said about Johnny he could
still go places I guarantee you if he
didn't back would have been busy yeah
well that's yeah that's true love you
buddy but I'm sorry yeah if you didn't
do that I can deal with a drunk I can
deal with a drug addict but I can't deal
with somebody who does domestic violence
yes that's why he fought that's why I
fought because you said at the start of
the when this case was that he was
willing to allow everybody to see his
ugly side because that's preferable that
to be to be called a Monster yeah
exactly speaking of monsters cat
I'm getting my own defamation lawsuit
get in line
what does this say about love cat it's a
very
skull strange animal one minute you're
the greatest thing ever ever in the next
you're in court what happens how did
this happen I don't think this is an
example of anything like I I just don't
I don't think I looked I've had
tumultuous relationships but they've not
reached the level plus I'm not a psycho
and most women are not complete psychos
who would do this right I kind of hate
treating this as some sort of referendum
on me too right because it's still true
that most women would not lie about
violent abuse just like most women would
not take it in your bed
uh I understand why people are concerned
because they say okay you know this will
make it harder because people will do
this to victims sometimes like oh it was
actually you said it was this day but it
was this day little nitpicky things
that's not what this is she's completely
lying yeah but she was completely crazy
so I think it's really important that we
do not equate Amber Heard with women
yeah I have a problem though with you uh
poop shaming her you're gonna start
a me number two movement well I think
she's I think
[Applause]
to make it about diarrhea
I gotta shut up
hey Sean Hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to Fox News YouTube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis you will not get it
anywhere else